hello and welcome to this video
Eve Eve Eva Jennie new new new account I
know it's got 700 plaits games played
okay
sometimes in you only see one rating
type you feel it's a very new account
but in this case it isn't ok c6 is a
conservative way of playing for black
we're definitely okay okay now we can
actually take or she can actually take
would have been a bit awkward hmm
interesting
I didn't I did not have a good way to
recapture then I was lucky okay
I want to go see forward without having
to fear the movie should be forward with
some pins okay
interesting
okay I'm going to take this so very
early
opening of the center here
what seem how she recaptures
now
this is so great for black I got be 45
if I played before now there is a bishop
cakes
III
that's that is
markable
before Bishop takes is three
you
huh interesting
before should takes an se5
also
should detour
- the Queen needs to move this is
definitely some serious compensation
okay interesting Bishop takes pawn takes
Queen takes check but should be 293 uses
a big big point and I cannot stop it so
aim is this was my idea so let's see
this should be pretty good compensation
the Queen now it's not sure where it
wants to go c7 probably maybe c6 maybe
c6 actually
yeah here I was thinking I just take and
play Bishop g3
then my bishop sits on d6 at the end
and se5 yeah but not sure if he five is
good
maybe maybe maybe she has to play that
really
that looks wrong
it looks wrong really okay so
three bishop g6
I can also just just check on b5 and and
let's do that first just stop canceling
King now has to move I know that won't
work it won't work
I don't I mean I would have I would have
had excellent compensation anyway a
bishop takes a was stronger even but
that's enough
okay and that was interesting I think
there were some spots there where I was
just not right here with my with my play
this this and now Quincy one is just a
bad move
I played this far too quickly funny it's
the Tory attack Torah check gossip
variation never heard of that what what
is a gossip variation yeah this is wrong
black here black can take and now I've
got a problem I cannot justify this this
is not good in particular because I mean
let's say I move the root K she even has
this for for this smooth very very bad
so this is a problem I probably have to
do this but this is just a pawn I don't
think I have enough compensation yeah I
can try this and we've got a bit of
development but as you see with the
computer email that's just bad
so Quincy one was a bad mistake Bishop
a5 yeah now it's kind of normal again
nothing happening I played a three which
is approved by the engine I think it did
it makes sense I want to play C 4 and C
form immediately Bishop b4 is a bit
awkward I thought maybe it isn't
actually I've got a three but okay it
takes takes may me I can still play that
anyway a3 wasn't terrible 97 C form c5
yeah and now we get to those interesting
complications so I captured and Bishop
takes yeah now this is an interesting
thing with before this is pawn sacrifice
the engine just wants to play Bishop b2
and delay this decision or to do with
the b-pawn yeah there's certainly edits
that's not bad
you you still have this option
a 5-2 stop it is not the ideal way to
play oh that is a very strong very nice
yeah that's very nice immediately found
by by stock fish of course now there's
this threat this threat and to Bishop
Hanks which is basically end of game
you know you have to see that between a
age is really end of game because there
is this Bishop looking the critical d8
square that is very nice of course I
didn't spot that one motivation behind
before was the thorn okay it's kind of
an unknown ever situation and I saw that
of course um that this is interesting
and with with the c5 this is why I took
a bit of time and I thought I saw this
position in a phone okay that should be
enough compensation or at least some
compensation the engine kind of approves
of that that there is some compensation
as I just give 0.44 black and you don't
know it's not very deep maybe it will
know it's on zero yeah we see here there
is some compensation I would be
surprised if black is better here Quincy
six looks better than Quincy seven
dollars really what I think but again I
think this wasn't bad it's just that
here you probably have to play e5 that
looks like the right decision if you
ninety five looks downright wrong I'm
not sure if I reviewed it and of course
but turn ninety five looks wrong getting
into that pin I was thinking if five and
now yeah I have to decide on how to
continue I thought I should always be
able to have enough pressure to justify
being a porn down something like the
first line in fact is what I would have
played f3 Bishop f5 at thought and be
should be five that was my thinking when
like this and you cancel there is there
some pressure here on those pawns and
it's quite likely that you get some some
of it back I don't know interesting
and this looks wrong so Bishop b5 seems
to be fine and now the King should go to
F Asia that looks like the most
reasonable way and then I would have
canceled and just played the position
like Quincy three rookie one like this
this and push the pawn it's a pretty
good attack the king is on evade so e5
yeah was necessary and now it just shows
immediately over yeah okay
interesting there were some chances for
black with 1962 it and that interesting
I think this is nice this is a very nice
motif here with B form and then all of a
sudden there are multiple threats and
black cannot cope with them very nice ok
yes thanks for watching